less than a month after it was reported
that Academy award-nominated actor Jonah
Hill was lined up to star alongside
Robert Pattinson in the Batman deadline
has dropped a bombshell Hill is no
longer in talks for the movie Hill
originally known for roles and raunchy
comedies took his career to new heights
with his astounding performances in the
wolf of Wall Street and the Netflix
series maniac was reportedly being
courted to portray a villain in the Matt
Reeves directed film though Warner
Brothers gave no explicit confirmation
owlets widely claimed that Hill would
play either the Riddler or Penguin
opposite Patton Suns Bruce Wayne sources
close to that line with knowledge of the
situation have indicated that talks
broke down between Hill and the power
suppiy that's Warner Brothers but why
exactly did those conversations stop
it's looking like the split was a mutual
decision and it may have at least
partially been over money but The
Hollywood Reporter Hill and Warner
Brothers simply couldn't quote come to
terms on a deal language that hints that
contractual negotiations may have been
the meet of the talks between the actor
and the studio Pele passing on the
Batman or Warner Brothers executives
telling him things just weren't going to
work out may actually have been weeks in
the making Variety reporter Justin Kroll
indicated in a now-deleted tweet on
September 25th 2019 exactly three weeks
before deadlines new reports that Hill
was sitting on the offer for the Batman
for over a month and that money was a
bargaining point in conversations with
Warner Brothers according to cross
sources Hill reportedly once said 10
million dollars more than double what
Pattinson is making for actually leading
the film those claims haven't been
corroborated but this wasn't coming from
some rumor sites its variety crawl also
noted that Hill and Warner Brothers may
have been torn between the two roles
unable to decide whether hit star is a
Riddler or penguin but it seems more
likely that money was the biggest
motivating factor if you're good at
something never do it for free
even with I'll tell the Batman has some
serious star power attached to it Reeves
who's known for directing the original
Cloverfield the horror remake let me in
and the sequels dawn of the Planet of
the Apes and war for the Planet of the
Apes is at the helm Pattinson who has
become something of an indie movie King
and has long since shed the weight of
his breakout role in the Twilight film
franchise is the title star Jeffrey
Wright will play Commissioner Gordon and
new
a deductr SIV Kravitz will dig her claws
into Catwoman
even without hill on board the Batman is
packing major heat and water brothers is
already looking to find someone just as
talented as hell to add even further
star power the studio is said to be
looking at new candidates to portray
either the Riddler or penguin in the
Batman and as for who those lucky actors
might be there have been some rumblings
about seth rogen another funny guy often
linked to Hill who has been breaking
ever more into fresher territory
potentially stepping up
however deadline notes that there was
only ever interested in Rogen for one of
the two roles with no offers or talks
yet occurring if one of Brothers
executives had their sights set on Hill
for either of the two iconic DC Comics
villains then it stands to reason that
the studio will probably go with someone
else like him a comedic actor who has
proven capable of bringing nuance to
life for performances to more dramatic
fare and he can also be threatening it
seems that's a trim with the Batman
casting going with an unexpected choice
for a major role Pattinson wasn't an
obvious pick for Batman and neither was
Hill for the Riddler or penguin right
may have also been a surprise pic for
summers Commissioner Gordon and though
Kravitz has played Catwoman before
voicing the anti heroine in the Lego
Batman movie her casting likewise raised
some eyebrows in related news Warner
Brothers has cast Paul Dano as the
Riddler alongside Patterson's Batman
according to The Hollywood Reporter you
might recognize Dano from his cellar
accolades in movies light there will be
blood 12 years a slave prisoners and
Swiss Army man the Batman will crusade
in two theaters without Jonah Hill on
June 25th 2021 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the Batman
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]